welcome to this video new part of
opening disasters yeah this game um was
chosen I mean particularly this game was
chosen because I was present when it was
played so this is why i picked exactly
this game and I could have picked others
because of this particular sequence of
moves has occurred quite a number of
times the critical position remove 14
has been played in the tone of
Grandmaster games which shows that you
can very easily I'm stumble into this
you could say okay move 14 who all kinds
of things can happen up to then true but
the sequence that this elite to this
disastrous situation is very very
logical and natural can easily happen i
had this in blitz games a number of
times for instances wide let's look at
the game yeah by the way to add some
information this was played in 2001 in
the interplay of event for the Dutch um
team competition was about it was
between I think then champion breda and
probably hilversum um and the two
players and were Han Suri further for
white I'm a veteran Grandmaster it's
close to 70 years who would know back
then he was in his late 50s still not
not not yeah he wasn't like a top player
at the time anymore I mean age is taking
its toll but still very decent player
with 2400 something and black players a
year on picket at the time I'm still an
active player he nowadays is retired he
played his last tournament a game in
2003 if my data
is correct he retired to become them
personal assistant of yo pun was the
wrong maybe known to some people as them
the guy who was responsible for
sponsoring the the tournament series
like melody ember those kindest rapid
tournaments he's not doing that anymore
but he also became the the world
correspondence chess champion where it
is commonly believed that actually
Pickett was playing that okay but let's
forget to that too much we get a Queen's
Indian defense normal opening of course
everything's fine for black and what
black is doing is playable but it
entails some risk we see later this is
all normal III who should be seven
Bishop d3 c5 yeah here and black has a
choice in this particular position he
can he should decide between three main
ways to play playing with c5 as he did
in the game play with d5 that's the main
move or you can also simplify my
simplify matters a bit by giving this
check yeah like Bishop d2 and taking on
92 c5 possible c5 is a playable choice
but it entails some risk we will see why
castles we should be 793 yeah here black
game must be must be cautious if he
castles then white can use this
opportunity to play d4 d5 and this is
not a very very good position for black
the problem is that the bishop on b7 is
not really well placed for any benoni
structure if we consider something like
that this is like a modern benoni where
the bishop is bad on
seven biting at this point and
additionally we have the bishop on e
seven which is also completely wrong in
the Benoni it wants to be on g7 to to do
something on the diagonal yeah what
about the pawn and like take yeah he can
theoretically speaking but check this
trade is quite advantageous for white
yet due to two reasons the d5 square is
a very weak black has a big deep on
which can be a problem and what you
shouldn't underestimate is black is
lacking his h porn so as king is also a
little bit insecure this is not like an
immediate mating attack but this can be
a problem later on if white has
activated to his pieces let's say Bishop
here p for Rupe t1 there could be some
mating attack coming I'm not a very good
position so black takes on d4 which is
very sensible due to this d 45 a DM
takes and now again black has a choice
if he castles he allows d5 again this is
a little bit different of course as now
we have see any pond traded still whiter
should have a good game here he is
limiting this Bishop considerably what
else is there black instead of Kessler's
he can also go d6 playing in the style
of the Hedgehog he however white has the
idea to play d5 again yeah black here
cannot take the pony on due to this
check check blundering everything but
normally play some yeah place ephi vm
and this is an interesting structure
with the bishop IAM being again badly
placed white has some interesting
options you can go for f form it's an
interesting position to play I think
white should be a little bit better
white can also play just rookie one and
continue from here with Bishop f4 or b3
Bishop between those kind of idea
us and these six however is pretty
pretty stubborn defence d5 is the the
more classical looking move and it is
still playable but very very difficult
for black to play now why it captures
night x and 95 this is the the key thing
about this specific line Black has
played a very quick b6 and Bishop e7 and
in this situation with 95 right in fact
has a very strong threat we should be
five check yeah and this the threat
basically forces black to Castle short
now which of course looks perfectly
normal and at first you do not really
see what the problem could be but it has
in fact some problems this move white
now has a choice he has two promising
continuations he can play as it was
played in the game Queen h5 or you can
play Queen g4 and this is a reason why
this whole setup is so dangerous for
black why does getting the Queen
involved in the kingside attack very
early and this as we see in the game can
lead to a very very quick defeat judge
Esther to prepare you what's coming the
game is over in five moves so can be can
be very quick defeat yeah it's not
totally clear if Queen h5 or queen g4s
better I probably would prefer Quincy
form but it's both interesting Queen age
five let's look at this this was played
in the game yeah how should black react
now it is already a critical as well
it's a maid threat and yeah what to
watch should he play um in the game he
played Knight f6 one of the
that is played there there also is g 6
and this move could be the reason why
Queen g4 is more precise as after g6 why
does not having a like a winning
continuation he has many promising
continuations but there is nothing that
really promises him a big advantage
Quincy form in this way is a bit better
after Queen g-form black has an addition
idea additional idea however the move f5
which looks ugly but at least avoid some
immediate disaster yeah Queen age 5
let's look what happened in the game
black plate Knight f6 which is still
possible it's not like indecisive but it
gets very problematical at least for
black Queen edge form yeah and in this
position black now went with knight c6
it looks totally normal right but in
fact this leads to two big problems here
black alternatively can play nitey for
an interesting move discovered discover
the tech after Queen 83 black can
consider to take after which miss Bishop
f4 is played in all this is very very
sharp but not totally clear not to let
Liam blackest is risking quite quite
something with playing this line but
it's not clear that he needs to be all
that he really should be be punished
here nitey formed is is interesting he
went knight c6 so ever and now after
Bishop g5 we see that again this may
threat is looming on age 7 how should
black defend now if he plays at age 6
has played for example by top check
grand master David navara some years ago
he was still young
layin on white is going Bishop f6 Bishop
f6 and Queenie for and this is very
embarrassing made threat and night is
saying so after G 696 navara was just
losing a piece for no compensation very
quick way to to lose yeah what else is
there yeah g6 was played in the game on
their black can play Knight xe5 the big
point being that after Bishop f6 main
threat on edge seven can be answered by
night XD 3 yeah the consequence is quite
clear white will take the exchange here
Bishop e7 Queen moves somewhere not sure
let's say here takes takes and in this
position why it is simply an exchange up
it's really just an exchange Black has
chances to to be are to continue the
fight II probably will get one pawn on
b2 r.d form but it's really just an
exchange this has been also been played
in GM games yeah we're black was just
trying to fight on with an exchange down
yeah Y&I takes d5 and exchange down it's
not so attractive yeah look at this
after g6 which was played in the game
right now has a great move available if
you don't know the whole thing you might
treat it as a little exercise and try to
find the best continuation here for
white you want can stop the video man
I'll be silent for a moment yeah right
now has a vinian continuation and it's
all based on the fact that there is big
pressure on c6e 7 f-6 this kind of
pressure now can be used with the very
nice move Bishop a6 and yeah after that
black is really losing there is really
no way around it anymore
Black now has no defense yeah the first
simple ideas of course if black takes on
a six we grab here and we'll win the
house their queen moves Jack and it's a
piece and also the Queen because queen
age six is coming otherwise black cannot
take on a six yeah so what what should
let place really yeah in the indie game
he took on e5 but we can look at
alternatives um what else is there in
some games h6 or stride for example x by
u de pagar y su reporte the the top
female player for 25 years now now
retired since a couple of weeks um yeah
she's super strong GM and she also
stumbled into into this line in 2010 um
yeah age six looks crazier but what
should you do Queen age six is the
refutation of this idea and after naija
form you play this neat little move yeah
it's it's really a bit mind-boggling
because everything hangs but there are
simply so much stuff hanging on the
black side that he or she in this case
cannot defend if we look at night GTX if
I for example we should be seven there
is really nothing that I can do if that
takes here we grab p.m. and if we do a
quick account white is a porn up and
this double oops is double attacking
those two so we will win at least an
exchange yeah in the game if we want to
look what what happened to poor girl and
how exactly did it went did it go up
bishop h6 um her opponent Grandmaster
halkias took with the bishop also good
move 95 and Bishop takes be seven yeah
here White is also winning after
this Queen 83 queen deform takes takes
and rookie one yeah why does an exchange
up and he only needs to be a bit
cautious that those active nights are
not causing any trouble but it's it's
still an exchange yeah black really has
no defense if we look at the last thing
to look at if we look at this white is
just retreating here with the Queen and
after Knight c3 which should be seven
again Hank's hangs and Hanks it's too
much like it's losing decisive material
yeah in the game here Pickett took only
five and we should that's important
actually and need to add that this was a
rapid game yeah it wasn't that it was a
30-minute game so the opening moves were
played very quickly and pick it really
stumbled into this I remember that I was
watching the whole thing it was a after
our own games had finished and this game
was basically over it started and was
over there was quite surprised to see
her to this line being played i knew of
this this is this opening trap and was
surprised to see it on such a high level
such a high level game it's funny array
and had to accept this earlier years ago
in the early ages in a game against
water brown okay night xe5 was played
and whites now captured and here after d
takes d5 Pickett already resigned yeah
there is absolutely no move now um 95 is
just answered by Bishop e7 and something
like this it's just a piece
yeah and if black takes here we grab f6
and this is an immediate intermedia to
move that were killed like this also the
mate so it's useless to continue this
fight so Pickett resides after 2015
moves yeah it's a very very nice
variation this this whole thing for
white and it it really happens quite
often I was experimenting a while ago i
was experimenting with the color system
with their with this opening here and
it's quite the remarkable quite often
people played c5 and Bishop d3 b6
castles Bishop b7c for a very often got
to learn the line in this fashion and
and I got the same attacking ideas going
so this is one one point of them the
college system if black is playing like
that we have some rather interesting
ideas but you should definitely go with
a c4 approach and not play the
relatively passive move c3 or 92 this is
really much more promising in comparison
yeah I hope you enjoyed this and maybe
you get an idea too um yeah to to to
incorporate this kind of playing idea in
your wide repertoire and well something
probably to avoid this black as well ok
I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching